[ Silence ]
>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Pause ]
>> Peg Clifton: I would like to
introduce to you Mr. Kirk Rascoe,
the Director of the Office
of Opportunity, Inclusiveness
and Compliance here at the library
who will introduce our speaker.
[ Noises ]
>> Kirk Rascoe: Thank you, Peg
Clifton [laughter] for this --
for the honor of having
to appear up here today.
The Library of Congress is
unique in the federal service.
It is the largest library in the
world, the research arm of Congress,
an exhibition center, an
international tourist destination,
a national cultural center and more.
As such, the diversity of American
society should be represented
at the Library in all of
its programs and activities.
The American people, members of
Congress, donors to the library,
scholars and dignitaries,
guests and visitors all expect
to experience the diversity
of the nation when they seek
to access the services and
programs of the library.
The Office of Opportunity,
Inclusiveness
and Compliance assists the
library fulfill its obligation
by exploring new avenues on which
to broaden the scope of services
and programs and to more fully
reflect the American experience
and all of its aspects.
In keeping with that mission,
we are responsible for assisting
with implementation of the
Americans with Disabilities Act.
The American with Disabilities
Amendment Act, ADAA --
there's the ADA and the ADAA -- and
Library Congress Regulation 2025-8.
Our advice covers the full spectrum
of obvious and hidden disabilities
in the following categories, death,
hard of hearing, blind, blind death,
low vision, dexterity, mobility,
medical and cognitive disabilities.
We also collaborate with the
assistive technology demonstration
center, a facility dedicated to
the evaluation and assessment
of assistive technology, some of
which you will learn about today
from today's speaker,
Dr. Michael Chorost.
Dr. Chorost is a technology theorist
with an unusual perspective.
His body is the future.
In 2001, he went completely deaf
and had a computer implanted
in his head to let him hear again.
This transformative experience
inspired his first book entitled
"Rebuilt: How Becoming Part
Computer Made Me More Human."
I guess it's like Frankenstein
in reverse [laughter].
He wrote about how mastering his
new ear, or cochlear implant,
enabled him to enhance his
greater potential as a human being.
In 2006, "Rebuilt" won the PEN USA
Book Award for Creative Non-Fiction.
Born in New Jersey, Dr. Chorost
earned his B.A. at Brown University
where he studied computer
programming, Renaissance drama
and cultural theory
on the way to his PhD
at the University of
Texas at Austin.
After graduate school, he worked
briefly at a dotcom in San Francisco
and then spent four and a half
years doing research in education
at SRI International in
Menlo Park, California.
His second book entitled "World
Wide Mind: The Coming Integration
of Humanity, Machines and
the Internet" proposes
that humanity can incorporate the
computer into its collective soul
in a way that enhances communities
and creative work instead
of diminishing them.
As a freelance science writer,
he has written for "Wired",
"The Washington Post",
"Technology Review",
and "The Scientist", among others.
He wrote the screenplay
for a television special
on brain implants entitled
"The 22nd Century",
which aired on PBS
in January of 2007.
He sits on external advisory
boards for neuroscience research
at Northwestern and Brown.
He now resides in Washington, D.C.
with his wife and their two cats.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Michael Chorost.
[ Applause ]
[ Noises ]
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: Thank you
very much for the introduction,
and I'm very grateful to
the Library of Congress
for inviting me here today.
So before I go on,
let's do a sound check.
I want to make sure everyone
can understand me all right.
Are you hearing me okay in back?
Okay. Very good.
Okay. If [inaudible] not, please
raise your hand and let me know,
because as a deaf person
with cochlear implants I have
a volume control on my ears,
so I am never quite sure of how loud
anything really is, so I always rely
on [inaudible] to let me
know if I can be heard.
So my talk today is called
"How to Put Your Brain
on the Internet: Lessons
from a Cyborg."
So this is the webcast on
YouTube, you can see directions,
and also I have a Twitter feed at
mikechorost, and if you want to put
out some tweets about
it, I'd be grateful.
So there's a hashtag chorostloc.
So my talk is going to start
with the lesson from the Cyborg,
grounded in my experience
as a cochlear implant user
and then it's going to talk
about how to put your brain
on the Internet, and
would you want to.
So let's talk about what brings me
here -- what brings me to this place
and talking about these
things, and the answer is
that I went abruptly deaf in 2001.
The story is that I was born with
severe to profound hearing losses.
I was not diagnosed until I
was about three and a half.
It was at that point
that I got hearing aids
and I began to learn English.
So I wore hearing aids
until I was 36 years old,
at which point I had dropped and
lost all of the remaining hearing
in my good ear, which
was my left ear.
So at that point I was too deaf to
get any benefit from hearing aids.
Nobody knows why that
happened, by the way.
The reason I was born deaf was
because my mother had rubella
when she was pregnant with me.
But why I went abruptly
deaf in one day
on July 7th, 2001 is still unknown.
Anyway, while the cause was
unknown, the treatment was not.
So I got a cochlear
implant in October 2001,
and at that point I immediately
started writing a book
because I'm a writer by nature.
I like to write about the
things that I go through.
So that experience resulted in
the publication of my first book,
"Rebuilt: How Becoming Part
Computer Made Me More Human",
and you can see the
hard cover edition there
and that's my own skull on the cover
and you can see the
implant in my skull.
So I'd like to think I'm the
only author in publishing history
with a picture of his head
on the outside and the inside
of the book jacket [laughter].
The book came out in paperback, and
so there's the paperback "Rebuilt:
My Journey Back to the Hearing
World," different subtitle,
the book is exactly the same
except that I fixed one typo.
And then a few years later I
published "World Wide Mind:
The Coming Integration of Humanity,
Machines and the Internet."
I was always fascinated by
technology and computers.
I did a lot of programming,
so when I ended
up getting a computer
inside my head,
I just ran with that opportunity
and starting writing books about it.
So let me walk you through
cochlear implant 101
so that you understand the kind
of technology that's in my head.
So let's start by pretending
that this is a normal ear,
without all this interesting
circuitry unit.
In a normal ear, sound will
come in through the ear canal,
hit the ear drum, which
makes these bones vibrate.
That vibration is transmitted
through the cochlea,
which is a hollowed tube filled
with liquid and tiny cells
that resonate in response to sound.
As those hear cells resonate,
these send sound signals
down the hearing nerve to the brain.
The reason that most
people are deaf is
that they lose those tiny
hair cells inside the cochlea.
It's like stripping the
keys off of a piano.
The strings are still there.
The piano can still create sound,
except that there's no keys
to trigger those strings.
Similarly, in my case, the
auditory nerve is intact,
it's just that there are no tiny
hairs left inside my cochlea
to vibrate in response to
sound, that's why I'm deaf.
So what a cochlear implant does is
it replaces that mechanical system
with an electronic system.
So let me walk you
through how that works.
Let's start with the outside.
So on the outside you can see
this thing called a "headpiece".
Now, that corresponds to this disc
that you see here,
specifically this thing.
Now, that headpiece, as you can
see, it actually sticks to my head.
Okay. Stupid implant
tricks [laughter].
That's because there's a magnet in
the headpiece that makes it stick
to a magnet inside
the implant itself,
so that explains why the
headpiece sticks there.
But, what is the headpiece?
Well, the headpiece
is taking a radio --
or rather it's taking an electronic
signal from the thing on my ear,
which is a string of ones and zeros.
It's digitized sound.
And it is sending that string of
ones and zeros through my skin
to the implant which is embedded
in my skull underneath the skin.
It's not inside my skull.
It's a not a brain implant.
It's on top of the skull,
countersunk into the
surface of the skull.
And I'll show you a wonderfully
gory picture of that in a moment.
>> Thanks for the warning.
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: Sorry, did
I hear somebody ask a question?
Yes?
>> [Inaudible], said
thanks for the warning.
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: Okay.
So the implant picks up the radio
signal and its job is to send
that signal down this wire
which terminates in a string
of electrodes inside the cochlea.
In this close-up, you can see that
string of electrodes [inaudible]
up inside the cochlea and here
are the little electrode plates.
Those are tiny electrodes
made of platinum and iridium,
and those electrodes are strobed
on and off in complex patterns
to activate the nerves inside
the center of the cochlea,
so this is the beginning of that.
So as these things trigger on
and off sending little shocks,
they force the nerves inside
the center of the cochlea
to send sound information down
the auditory nerve to the brain.
So that's what a cochlear
implant does.
It replaces the mechanical
system of the inner ear
with an electronic system
that sends digital information
into the auditory cortex
of the brain.
Amazing technology.
So that's cochlear implant 101.
Now, let me show you a
real cochlear implant.
And this is a slide
that I love to show just
after lunch hour [laughter].
So you can see here, this
is a cochlear implant.
It's not my cochlear
implant, by the way;
it's somebody else's
cochlear implant.
It has just been installed in the
surface of the skull and you can see
that the skin is still retracted,
so the surgeon has
not yet closed it up.
But you can see that the surgeon
has countersunk it into the skull
so that the surface is almost
flush with the top of the skull.
You can also see that he has
tied it down with metal sutures
so that it doesn't go anywhere.
And if you look closely, you can
also see that there's a little bit
of brand information on the implant.
It says "Advanced Bionics,
[inaudible] Platinum II, Model,"
such and such, "This
side out [laughter]."
I just love the fact that I have
a part of my body and labeled
"This side out [laughter]."
And if you think about it for a
minute, the reason is obvious.
If [inaudible] one side out, the
magnet will be facing the wrong way
and the headpiece would fly off
of my head instead of sticking.
So the two magnets have to
stick to each other to make
that radio signal go through.
And you can see here the
beginning of the electrode array,
which is going down through a
tunnel that the surgeon has drilled
through the bone down
to the inner ear.
That drilling goes in
about an inch and a half.
The electrode array -- if you
take an x-ray of my skull,
the electrode array is right
behind the pupil of my iris.
Okay? So if you look in my
eye you can see how deep
that electrode array
is going into my head.
So it's quite a remarkable surgery.
By the way, it goes very fast.
My first implant was installed
in about an hour and a half,
the second one in about 41 minutes.
I went in the morning, went home
the afternoon and newly wired up.
You know, if you could open up
that casing and look inside,
this is what you would see.
You would see a bunch of
chips, a bunch of resistors
and all sorts of little wires.
So when I first went deaf, I went to
an audiologist and she showed me one
of these things and I felt it
in my hand and stared at it
and I thought, "Oh my God.
They're really going to
put this thing inside me.
What's that going to be like?
How will this mask of silicon
and resistors actually
replace a part of my body?"
So I'll tell you a
little bit about that.
So very briefly, this is
how the software works.
So I showed you before that
the electrode array is curled
up inside the cochlea.
It's got 16 electrodes.
The electrodes that are all
the way at the basal end here,
when those electrodes flash on
and off, they stimulate nerves,
they're used to code in
high frequency sounds.
When the electrodes all the way the
tip of the array flash on and off,
these stimulate nerves that are used
to getting low frequency sounds,
so the software breaks
up sound by frequency.
It takes all the high pitches
and sends them down here.
It takes all the low pitches
and it sends them down there.
So it takes sound apart kind of the
way a coin sorter would take coins
and sort them by the
size of the coin,
and it will send the
appropriate frequencies
to the appropriate
part of the cochlea.
So you may wonder, how many
people have this technology.
Is it new?
Is it experimental?
The answer is, no, it's not.
It's been around the 1990s.
And there's about 219,000
people with implants worldwide
since the technology became
commercial in the very late 1980s.
So you may wonder, is
that a lot or a little?
Well, to give you a
little bit of perspective,
in the United States alone
there are about 500,000 people
who have hearing losses severe
enough to make them candidates
to get a cochlear implant; half
a million in this country alone,
and yet worldwide there's
less than a quarter
of a million implant users.
So what that tells you is that
this technology is still very much
underused, that there are
many people who could benefit
from this technology
who don't have it.
And there are many reasons
for that, economic reasons,
reasons of knowledge, reasons of
what doctors believe and so forth.
So even though the technology
has been around for decades,
it is still very much
an emergent technology.
So now, let me give you an
inkling of what the world sounds
like to me with a cochlear implant.
So I'm going to play you
a couple of sound files
and let me tell you
what this is about.
You're going to hear what
sounds like an English sentence
that has been electronically
filtered to resemble the output
of a cochlear implant, and your
challenge will be to figure
out what the sentence is.
I'm going to play you a couple
of versions of that sentence.
The first version, the four-channel
version, roughly corresponds
to what some of the
very earliest users
of experimental cochlear
implants heard,
because at that time they had
only four or six electrodes.
They were very primitive
devices by today's standards.
When my first cochlear
implant was first turned on,
the software gave me the
equivalent of eight electrodes.
I'm simplifying here because at
that point even though there were 16
electrodes in the electrode array,
the software treated
each pair of them
as if it was a single electrode.
So I got, in effect, eight
electrodes worth of information.
Then a year later, I got new
software that made each electrode
in individual channel,
giving me 16 channels.
So I'm going to play
you four, eight and 16.
Let's see if you can figure
out what the sentence is.
>> [Sound recording]
I like to play tennis.
>> Dr. Michael Chorost:
I'll play it again.
>> [Sound recording]
I like to play tennis.
>> Dr. Michael Chorost:
Can anybody make that out?
>> Yeah.
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: No takers?
>> I like to play to tennis?
>> Dr. Michael Chorost:
I like to play tennis.
Any other guesses?
>> Shush?
>> Dr. Michael Chorost:
Shush [laughter]?
Well, if you listen to it, you can
actually kind of hear that shush.
Let me play that again.
That's a finer pointer.
It always gets lost on this slide.
>> [Sound recording]
I like to play tennis.
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: I think
[inaudible] end, you sort of hear
that [makes sounds] kind
of sound, don't you?
Okay. So who thinks it's,
I like to play chess?
>> [Inaudible response].
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: Okay.
It could be that, right?
All right, now eight channels.
And when you hear this, you'll
hear a pretty good rendition
of what things sounded like to me on
that first day back in October 2001.
I have to find a pointer.
>> [Sound recording]
I like to play tennis.
>> Dr. Michael Chorost:
Okay, any guesses?
Well, I'm seeing people nodding.
Okay. How many people feel sure
that it's, I like to play tennis?
[Background talking]
Okay, a bunch of you.
You know, about a year later, in
2002, I was upgraded to 16 channels
and that was not a surgical process,
they just put new software
in the processor.
There's actually a little data port
in which the audiologist
can plug a port
and they just transferred new
software into the processor,
so it's very easy to get upgraded.
Here's 16 channels.
Let's use the finder.
There we go.
>> [Sound recording]
I like to play tennis.
>> Wow, [inaudible] [laughter].
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: So
you can hear the difference.
You hear that the 16-channel
version is smoother
than the 8-channel version.
But now let me play you the
original unedited sound file.
>> [Sound recording]
I like to play tennis.
>> Dr. Michael Chorost:
Big difference, right?
So there are two lessons to
be drawn from this slide.
The first lesson [background
sounds] is
that a cochlear implant does not
give you super human hearing.
It is not Jamie Summer's Bionic
Woman, X-man kind of hearing.
On the other hand,
it is usable hearing.
It allowed me to use the
telephone, listen to the radio,
have conversations, even in
noisy rooms and in restaurants.
So that's a lesson to be
drawn from that slide.
Okay. So now we've done
cochlear implant 101 --
cyborg 101, or rather,
modern-day cyborg 101.
So we'll talk about what this
technology means for the future.
So let's talk about some emerging
neuroprosthetic technologies.
So this is a video --
there's no sound in the video,
it's just the video -- that
shows a double amputee.
He lost both of his arms.
He was an electrical linesman.
He was electrocuted;
both of his arms had
to be amputated at the shoulder.
So people are working on building
externally wearable prosthetic arms
for him to use.
So, these arms are getting their
information from those electrodes
that you can see on his
back; they are picking
up the twitches of his muscles.
And in fact, surgeons have actually
moved around the nerve [inaudible]
to different places on his
back and his shoulder so that
when he imagines a given
set of muscle motions,
muscle will actually twitch
in his back and on his chest
and the electrodes pick
up those twitchings --
those twitches and they figure
out what he is trying to do
and they make the arm do it.
So this is an example of
what's state-of-the-art
in prosthetic arms today.
And you'll notice, by the
way, he's wearing goggles,
so they're clearly not
entirely sure of the safety
of these devices yet [laughter].
So let me tell you
two things about this.
On the one hand, it's
incredibly impressive.
He's actually controlling
this thing fairly well.
On the other hand, it
still falls very far short
of reproducing a natural arm.
First of all, he gets no
sensory feedback from the arm,
so he only knows where
it is by looking at it.
Second, the software is
only sophisticated enough
to decode one motion at a
time, so, it's hard for them
to just move smoothly and
do several things at a time.
It's more like he's
got to move the elbow,
move the wrist and move the elbow.
He has to decompose the motion
and execute them one at a time.
So it is both impressive and
underwhelming at the same time.
So this shows you kind
of the cutting edge
of how much information we can
get of what the brain wants
and reading muscles on
the outside of the body.
There's nothing going on with
the technology in his brain
for this particular technology.
So what if you could
go to the brain?
Now, this is something that I
wrote about in a story I wrote
for "Wired Magazine" last year, it's
called "Waiting for the Bionic Man."
So you can actually just find it
online by doing a Google search
for "wired bionic arm" and my last
name, "Chorost," C-H-O-R-O-S-T.
It's how I explored some of the
things that prosthetic arms can do,
but also why it is still so
difficult to make them behave
as well as naturally
performing arms.
Okay. People are trying to get into
the brain itself to figure out how
to read information out of
the brain because that's
where the information is.
It's like this is my [inaudible]
because that's where the money is.
This is why researchers are trying
to get in the brain because that's
where the code is that tells you
what the brain is trying to do.
So this is very primitive
technology that I actually tried.
Now, that's me wearing
a cat with electrodes
and what this does is I'm
looking at that computer screen
and various letters are
flashing on and off.
It's flashing one letter at a time.
And I'm just looking at a letter
and waiting for it to flash.
When it flashes, there's a
perceptible signal that goes
on in the visual cortex where the
visual cortex is saying, "Hey,
something just happened."
When that happens that a peer
knows that what I was looking
at it has just been lit
up and it puts that letter
on the screen up on top here.
So it's actually very
simple technology.
It's just looking for
activation in the visual cortex
and it works surprisingly well.
I was able spell out "Hello
out there" just by looking
at different letters on this screen.
So it's a really interesting
technology
but it's still external to the body.
Okay. What if I go inside?
Well, this is a new video
-- well, not that new.
It's about two years old now.
This is of a woman who is
paraplegic, completely paralyzed,
and she had implants installed
in her brain in the motor cortex,
the part that controls the arm.
And that implant is being used
to drive the robotic
arm that you see here.
So you can see on the top of
her head, that is the plug
that is actually picking
up electrical signals put inside
her motor cortex, data is being sent
to the computer and the
computer is trying to figure
out from her brain
activity what she is trying
to do with the robotic arm.
And you can see that A, it
does kind of work and, B,
it's not ready for prime time.
So, again, we have that combination
of amazing and underwhelming
and you will see in a moment
she will get it up to her mouth.
[ Pause ]
So I was told by John Donahue
[assumed spelling] who is the PI,
the principal investigator, of this
study that this was the first time
since she had been paralyzed that
she was able to pick up a cup
and bring it to her
own mouth by herself.
[ Pause ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Inaudible Conversations ]
[ Pause ]
Now, she's got to get it
back down on the table.
[ Pause ]
[ Applause ]
So it's really quite amazing
what the technology can do,
but we're still trying to
grapple with the question
of how much further can you go
with this kind of technology.
Well, I'll show you a short clip
from a TV show that I wrote back
in 2007 asking, well, how
do you get inside the brain?
And here's one possible way.
And this video does have
audio, so if you can't hear it,
raise your hand and
I'll turn the volume up.
>> [Inaudible] excited because
for the first time there was a way
to access the brain [inaudible], and
the brain being such a vital organ,
it's quite understandable
you want to leave it alone.
So the technology is there.
Now, the question will be,
[inaudible] you actually put
in the nanowires exactly
at the place you want.
The answer is no, you can't.
But, nanowires are very small,
so [inaudible] is very small
which is [inaudible] that's
about, you know, 100 times less
than the thickness of your hair.
How do you push the
electrode to the brain?
So what you do is you actually send
a certain number [inaudible] bundle
and then the bundle
would probably be --
I mean, nanowires would be allowed
to float into the blood stream
until they can go no further.
At the moment we can wire a rat.
We can [inaudible] the
electrodes in the spinal cord.
We want to know if we do so,
how long would the wires
continue to work properly.
We're talking about five years
where it's a very basic
research that needs to be done.
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: So, that's
one idea that's being floated
around of actually wiring up
the brain from the inside.
I personally am not too optimistic
about that particular technology
because the issues of tangling
and clotting seem to me just to be
so formidable as to pretty much
rule this out as a possibility.
But there are other possibilities
which are actually quite
a bit further along.
So, a year or two ago I wrote
another story in "Wired"
about a technology
called optogenetics.
It's not a very glamorous
sounding name.
Optogenetics, what's that?
What it is is its using light
to make genetically altered
neurons fire or stop firing.
So let me explain a little bit
further what optogenetics is
all about.
With a technology like optogenetics,
you start by putting
altered genes --
or rather, you start by
putting genes inside the neurons
in a particular part of the brain.
Well, what genes?
You take genes from plants.
What genes from plants?
You take the genes from plants
that make them respond to light.
So we know that plants
do respond to light.
A leaf will move toward the sun.
Plants are phototropic.
You could actually take the gene
that makes plants do that and put
that gene inside a neuron
inside the mammalian cortex.
And so when a light is shown on that
neuron, it will then actually fire.
So you can set it up -- the details
get very complicated and I talk
about them at length in my book,
"World Wide Mind", but you can set
up a neuron so that when you're
showing blue light on it,
that neuron will start to
fire and only that neuron.
The other neurons around
it don't fire.
It's possible to make this
technique so specific you can choose
to fire only selecting neurons out
of a bunch of thousands or millions.
Conversely, you can also use yellow
light to make your own stop firing.
When you're showing a yellow
light, the neurons are inhibited.
So you can actually turn on
and off selected neurons just
by showing new lights on them.
And a way to do this is to put light
emitting diodes underneath the skull
on top of the brain where they
actually illuminate brain tissue
with red and yellow light and
other wavelengths as well.
So you actually get to control
neurons on the cortex of the brain
which is where most cognition takes
place without actually having to cut
into the brain or to try to
send nanowires into the brain
from the other direction
through the capillaries.
So this is opening
up the possibility
of creating brain implants that
just sit on top of the brain.
And let me show you a mouse to
whom this has actually been done.
So this video, I'd like to
show it to you twice for you
to really understand
what's going on.
So you're going to see a mouse
[inaudible] plastic tank.
What you can't see is that there is
a fiber optic cable that is hanging
down and going into the mouse's
brain; and that cable is being used
to send blue light into the mouse's
motor cortex, or more accurately,
into one-half of the
mouse's motor cortex.
So when blue light illuminate,
half of the mouse's motor cortex
that controls the arms
and legs on one side,
both arms and legs start to run.
Since the other ones are not
being stimulated, what happens?
The mouse goes in a circle, right?
If you think about it, if you could
only move your right arm and leg
and you were on all fours, it
would end up going in a circle.
So that's what's going on here.
So I'll play it again and watch
very carefully for the blue light
that shines in the mouse's head
and as that blue light turns on,
the mouse will start to run
in a counterclockwise circle.
When the light is turned
off, the mouse will stop.
Okay, watch again.
Okay. So light's not on yet, so in
a second it's going to be turned on.
Now, okay, it's running around
because it can't help it.
Its brain is being forced to fire,
the neurons in his motor cortex
that make the legs on one side
move; and when it stops, it stops
and so it looks up, you know, "What
the heck just happened [laughter]?"
So it doesn't look dramatic.
There's a mouse running around
in a circle, but what's dramatic
about it is, it's showing it the use
of information light that's being
used to precisely control one thing
that a mouse does and that's
doing one precise thing.
It's running around in a circle.
It's not having a convulsion,
it's not pressing levers,
it's not feeling hungry; it's
just doing one particular thing.
So what is this telling us that when
you're beginning to figure out --
and I really mean just beginning --
beginning to figure out how to
decompose activity in the brain
to figure out what it means?
When this neuron, that neuron and
this neuron and that neuron fire,
what does that correspond to?
We're just trying to figure out
those kinds of relationships
and here's an example of the paper
that came out a few years ago.
In the early [inaudible] of the
concepts of nest in the mouse brain.
So to figure out which
neurons activate
when the mouse sees its nest.
So the ultimate idea is that
all the things that we think
of as immaterial thought is
our ideas, our perceptions,
our feelings, our bodily
sensations, our hungers,
all of these are ultimately
represented and caused
by specific pattern of
neural activity in the brain.
You know, in reality, it is
extraordinarily complicated.
Researchers have found that when
animals like monkeys make but looks
like the same motion, different
sets of neurons will fire.
So it's clearly very complicated.
It's not a simple as oh,
neurons X, Y, Z fire,
that means that this is happening.
The relationships are much
more complex than that.
That's partly because the
brain is constantly changing
and it's constantly learning.
So, for example, when you
train a mouse to move its arm
in a certain way and
watch neurons fire.
If you then put a weight on
that monkey's arm so that it has
to work a little bit harder
to make the same motion,
you'll see different neurons fire
because the brain is adjusting,
to learn how to make the arm
move the same way even though the
situation has changed.
So the neural code is not
[inaudible] a solid thing
like an alphabet or a language;
it is a constantly changing thing.
And the challenge is trying to
figure out how to understand
that well enough to be able
to actually intervene in it,
to figure out what it means
and to make neurons fire
to make the brain experience a
particular sensation or taste
or hunger or thought or feeling.
Now, if you think this
sounds completely outlandish,
consider for a moment
that my cochlear implant is sending
electrical signals to my brain
that makes my brain
believe that it's here.
I'm completely deaf.
I have no biological hearing
and yet researchers had figured
out the auditory code of the
brain well enough to enable me
to hear something that sounds
pretty much like normal English.
So to give [inaudible] details
[inaudible] optogenetics.
So as I said before, it can fire
or inhibit just one type of neuron,
let's say, motor neurons,
that control the arm while
leaving all the others unaffected.
And because you're injecting viruses
into the tissue to insert the gene
into those neurons, you can very
much limit where it happens just
by only injecting the viruses
that carry those genes
into particular areas.
And so with refinements, which I
talked about in "World Wide Mind,"
it's potentially possible to
activate only specific neurons
and to detect only, when to
detect which neurons fire
when a given action
or a given perception
or a given thought happens.
So optogenetics has really
transformed neuroscience.
It's allowed researchers to really
begin dissecting the actual neural
basis of thought and action.
So here's a paper that came out
just recently and got quite a lot
of press, you may have
heard about it.
In fact, I haven't
given you a reference
because you can just find
it by Googling phrase like
"brain-to-brain interphase real time
sharing," the paper will come up.
It's an Open Access paper.
And this was in the lab of Miguel
Nicolelis at Duke University,;
and he reported that he had
gotten one rat to be able
to send a mental signal to another
rat to tell that rat which lever
to press, the right
one or the left one.
Okay? So let's dig
into that a little bit.
When I first read about the study,
here's what I thought
they were doing.
So, they had two rats and they both
have arrays of electrodes implanted
in their brains and those electrodes
can both detect neural activity
and trigger neural activity.
It goes either way.
So what I thought they were doing
is they were having the sender rat
pressing a left or
a right bar, okay,
depending on which
light flashed above it,
and then the computer picked up a
certain pattern of neural activity
that they had previously
learned and corresponded
to pressing, say, the left bar.
And that they sent a
simple code, you know,
it's like a certain
sensation to another mouse
with an implanted electrode
array and that mouse had learned
when I had this sensation,
I pressed the left bar,
when I had that sensation,
I pressed the right bar.
That's what I thought it
was, so, I was like, oh,
that's not such a big deal
because you just do that just
by implanting electrodes and
training a mouse to do something
when it has a certain sensation.
Big deal. So what?
Well, I read the paper very
carefully a couple of times
and this is what's really happening.
So the sender mouse, which is the
one on the left, presses the left
or the right bar -- let's
say it's the left bar.
The pattern neural activity that
corresponds to that is picked up
and recorded and it's processed to
basically clean it up a little bit,
and then that actual data, the
cleaned-up version of that data,
is sent to the receiver's brain.
So whatever neural pattern fires,
whatever they detect in the sender,
they clean it up a little bit
and they send it to
the receiver's brain.
So the receiver mouse is getting
a slightly filtered version
of what's actually going on
in the sender rat's brain.
And if that mouse actually
presses the left bar,
the sender mouse gets a reward; the
sender mouse gets a drink of water,
so that when the sender
mouse gets it right,
it gets rewarded for that activity.
So it learns, if I press the
bar this way, if I just do it
in this certain way, I get rewards.
So there is actually a kind of
circular communication going
on here between the mice.
Now, I started asking
some questions.
The success rate of this
was between 60% and 72%,
which is not actually incredibly
good when you think about that
by chance alone you will
get a 50% success rate.
Okay? So clearly there
were lots of times
when the sender pushed the left bar
and the receiver either did nothing
or pressed the other bar, so
it's clearly not fool-proof yet.
You can kind of see this pattern
of [inaudible] up is both amazing
and underwhelming, right?
This idea comes up
over and over again,
but it raises some very
interesting questions.
So do the rats think they're
communicating or do they just think
that stuff is happening in their
heads and they're pressing bars?
And the paper really doesn't answer
that question as far as I can tell.
Can the rats see each other?
Do they actually know that
they are communicating?
I'm not clear on that.
The other question I think is
actually more interesting is
that the receiver rat feels that
it's responding to a signal;
is it thinking, "Oh, I'm
getting this kind of sensation,
I'm going to press the left bar,"
or, is it actually being forced
to press the left bar because the
neurons in his brain [inaudible]
when the left bar gets pressed is
actually -- are actually firing.
So [inaudible] just pushing
that bar because it thinks just
as if it had decided
to do it itself.
So that's a very interesting
question.
We may not know the answer to
that until we are able to get --
stop working with rats and
start working with people
because you can't interview
a rat and say, "Well,
what do you think happened?"
It raises all these very
interesting questions.
So in the paper, I was looking at --
quoted you what it said at
the very end of the paper,
which is kind of both mind
blowing and [inaudible] okay.
So he says, "In theory, channel
accuracy," and this is the accuracy
of how well it works, "can be
increased if instead of [inaudible],
a whole grid of multiple
reciprocally interconnected brains
are employed."
So let's talk about wiring
together a whole bunch of rats.
All right.
Well, what do you get from that?
Such a computing structure
could define the first example
of an organic computer capable
of solving heuristic problems
that would be deemed non-computable
by [inaudible] machine.
Well, this will mean more
if you're a computer geek.
Okay? But what they're saying
in plain English is that, A,
if you connect a whole bunch
of rats together we think
something interesting is going
to happen but we're not sure what.
And they're suggesting that
maybe this interconnected set
of rats will be able to do things
that rats have never been able
to do before, whatever that is.
So, I started thinking about,
"Well, could you do this to people?"
And [inaudible] that the answer is,
in theory, yes, okay, in theory.
There's obviously a lot
of technical challenges
to solve, but in theory, yes.
So let's say you had an
implanted optogenetic array
in the left person's brain and
that person thinks of an apple,
a certain set of neurons fire.
So that person's implanted
array picks up that set
of firings and decodes it.
Oh, this means a person
is thinking of an apple.
And then sends a code over the
Internet which just consists
of the word "apple," okay,
nothing very complicated,
just the word "apple", and
[inaudible] the array, picks that up
and it knows which neurons to
activate in that person's brain
so [background talking] you
then have the perception
of seeing an apple.
So you've sent a perception
of seeing something
through the Internet, these would
be literally two brains connected
by this kind of Internet system.
And in "World Wide Mind" I
called this "telempathy,"
to talk about the fact that this is
nonverbal information that's being
sent, and that would be
the interesting thing.
Sending speech, well, we've
got a technology to do that,
it's called a cell phone.
What's more interesting is sending
things that we cannot now send
over the wires, feelings,
perceptions,
sensations, ideas, eventually.
So let me just [inaudible]
a whole bunch
of long disclaimers as I wind down.
We are still struggling to
understand the neural code.
It is still essentially
impossible to just look at a brain
at its neural firing and figure
out what that brain is doing.
All we can really do now is
record a brain's activity
as it does something where we know
what it's doing, pressing a lever,
seeing an apple, and then, if we
see the brain doing that, again,
we figure, oh, the brain must be
seeing an apple or pressing a lever.
It's a one-to-one correspondence.
But there's no way as
yet of understanding the
general code of the brain.
If this electrode -- [inaudible]
this neuron, that neuron,
that neuron, that neuron,
these neurons fire,
all that means is a person
thinking of the "Wizard of Oz".
[Inaudible], okay?
And I think [inaudible]
is stupendously difficult.
It's kind of like Robert Goddard
launching his first rocket that went
up 30 feet and then extrapolating
from that [inaudible] say, "Oh,
we'll be able to get to the moon."
Well, we could, it's just that we're
still at that Robert Goddard stage.
I also argued in "World Wide Mind"
that this technology would not
work unless you had [inaudible]
communicative context.
So unless person A and person B
are in a context where thinking
about an apple makes sense, just
sending these signals is just going
to seem like nonsense, so
they're going to need a way
of actually having a contact in
which these signals make sense.
And finally, you need safe, easy and
cheap brain surgery, which is going
to be something [inaudible] to
get past the FDA [laughter].
Okay? Still, to wrap up, and we have
a couple of minutes for questions.
I just wanted to point out that
cochlear implants were a crazy idea
in 1975.
Otolaryngologists at that time
were saying, it's impossible.
You couldn't fit that much
computational power inside
the brain.
You couldn't figure out the
auditory code of the ear.
You couldn't surgically implant it.
Forget it.
That's nonsense.
And yet indeed, it did happen.
So with that note I want
to say thank you very much
for coming and for listening.
[ Applause ]
So we have about six
minutes for questions, okay.
So I'm inviting you to raise a
question, and if I can't hear you,
I may just trot over, or, you know,
maybe you can just [inaudible]
question [inaudible] hear it better
than I can.
Okay. Yes, sir?
>> You're talking about stimulating
the nerve endings with [inaudible],
do you know any research
[inaudible] with multiple sclerosis
where the brain is damaged
and it might be possible
to rewire the damaged
part of the brains,
[inaudible] to regain mobility?
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: Okay.
I've heard parts of that
but I'll need some help.
>> Multiple sclerosis...
>> Hmm-mm.
>> ...if the brain is --
is there any research done
to rewire the brain?
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: Okay.
[Inaudible].
So the question is, is
there a research going
on to actually use a
technology to help people
with brain disorders
like multiple sclerosis?
I don't know about MS,
but for Parkinson's, yes.
So there is actually quite a bit
of research going on especially
at Stanford to look at
what the brain stops doing
with patients [inaudible]
Parkinson's.
And so there is active talk of
creating optogenetic technologies
to implant in Parkinson's
patients to stimulate the neurons
that are not firing or are firing
because the patient has Parkinson's
to replicate that person's
ability to control their body.
So, yes, the optogenetics
is very much being thought
up as a possible treatment
for those kinds of problems.
And in fact, I wrote a story about
this in "Wired", so if you go to --
if you do a Google search -- well,
it's actually powered by photons,
so if you Google search with
"powered by photons," you'll come
to the story I wrote in "Wired"
where the principal
investigator started
with that as a main motivation.
He wanted to figure out
how to cure Parkinson's.
And he started doing
research on mice
that actually had Parkinson's
disease;
they were genetically engineered
to have Parkinson's, and they found
that there were [inaudible] ways
actually of making them walk again.
So, yes, this is very much an
active area of research right now.
Okay, question.
Yes, sir?
>> Hi, I'm [inaudible] and I have
a couple of questions for you.
I'm curious about your use of the
word "cyborg" in one of your books.
I thought that can be kind
of offensive to deaf people.
And also you're talking about the
500,000 people who are deaf here
in America that you mentioned and
you're trying to cure them or,
I mean, [inaudible] genocide?
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: Okay.
This is a very complex issue and
I'm glad you raised that question.
I actually talked about it in
length in both of my books.
So I also spent a year
at Gallaudet University,
so where I was learning a
little bit of sign language.
I don't know enough to
really have a conversation
because I never learned
sign while growing up,
but I've certainly
thought about this question
in a great deal of depth.
So it's very -- there's very much
a split in the deaf community
between people who are
native sign users and people
who have been brought oral, who
grow up using English like me.
So just to give the
audience some background,
people who are native sign
language users, who are immersed
in that community, are
concerned that the use
of cochlear implants will
undercut that community.
Because if a child gets
a cochlear implant,
they often can hear well enough
to grow up speaking English
or another spoken language instead
of going to a sign and deaf school
and learning sign language.
So that's the concern.
So I know I'm not answering your
question yet, but let me ask you,
would you like to follow up?
>> I have one more.
[ Silence ]
You mentioned -- [inaudible]
[laughter].
>> Talk about the use
of the "cyborg"...
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: That's okay.
>> For hearing people [inaudible]
hearing [inaudible] channels,
so I'm not sure [inaudible]
if we would call
that [inaudible] successful
putting them
into children [inaudible] hearing,
but also [inaudible] I think
that people -- it makes
us seem like it's
against deaf people [inaudible]
use of that term, "cyborg,"
it seems like you kind
of hate deaf people.
I mean, I grew up in
[inaudible] school,
it's not that I wasn't
successful there, and [inaudible].
So my question is, I'm asking
you, do you hate deaf people?
>> Dr. Michael Chorost:
Okay, challenging question.
Of course, I don't hate deaf people.
Okay. That's the simple
answer to your question.
I went and spent a year at Gallaudet
University, I'm deaf myself.
Here's what I think is going on.
96% of deaf children are born to
parents who have normal hearing.
Those parents don't
know sign language.
They have no exposure
to sign language .
96%. So the doctors says to those
parents, "I have a technology
that will enable your
child to hear and to grow
up speaking your language."
What do you think those
parents will do?
In almost every instance, they
will take the cochlear implant.
So there's no conspiracy here.
Nobody hates deaf people, it's just
that 96% of deaf children are born
to parents who don't know anything
about deafness, and those parents,
very understandably, I would
say, they want to raise a child
in their own language
in their own culture.
So that's what's going on.
[ Silence ]
[ Noises ]
>> We have a limited amount of time
for questions in the program today,
so we can continue this discussion
after the program outside.
If there are any other questions...
>> Okay.
>> ...otherwise, we'll wrap up.
Any other questions.
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: So
we'll take one more question.
Yes, sir?
>> [Inaudible] to using this kind
of technology, or these kinds
of technologies to
transmit a nonnative sensory
and put it into humans?
So take all kinds of data that
on the Internet, for example,
and transmitting data to the mind?
>> Dr. Michael Chorost: Okay.
So the question is, iss
there any research into --
you used the word "nonnative" into
[inaudible] say "nonstandard" kind
of information, things we don't
normally hear or feel or see?
It's a fascinating question.
I think that's an idea
that many people have.
At this point it's a -- I
wouldn't quite say it's a fantasy,
but it's a hope.
I think that's the kind of thing
that Miguel Nicolelis was talking
about at the end of his article
when he talked about linking groups
of brains together, to
see what would happen,
to see what is possible.
So in my book "World Wide Mind,"
I suggested that this kind
of technology could be used to
facilitate group communication
in a way that's imagistic.
So, for example, if you have a group
of people in a dangerous situation
and one of them gets
hurt, you may be able
to transmit a [inaudible] sensation
of pain immediately to everyone else
in the group so that
everybody instantly knows, "Oh,
John has just been injured,"
[inaudible] immediately reacts
to that rather than to have to shout
and try to explain and so forth.
So, I think the most exciting
use of these technologies is not
to do better things that we do
today, but rather to enable us
to do entirely new things that
we can't even imagine now,
and this is what the
Internet has been all about.
So when email came out in the
1990s, most people thought, "Oh,
this is just a better way
to write [inaudible]."
But of course, as we all know,
it completely changed corporate
and personal and social
communication in a way
that could not have been imagined.
And I would expect to
see [inaudible] to go
on if this technology ever
becomes safe and useful.
Okay, we have to wrap up.
So I've got books out there.
I'd be delighted to sign any books
that you would be delighted to buy,
and thank you all so
much for coming out.
I really appreciate it.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.